i
get this sense yeah because we were
driving down paul here
he's uh our editor extraordinaire we
call him el chapo
and uh paul had this this he's like you
know man it's crazy how
tony hawk has been so famous such an
icon for so long
but it's just always seemed that he's
been
just very level-headed always had his
head screwed on
at no point does it ever seem like he
went off the rails like fame got to him
or any like
crazy stuff like that and uh i think
that that's a really accurate thing
to point out and you know i think that
that
you know like i i think it's safe to say
that that your relationship with your
mom
and with your dad is you know and then
and then beyond that with
stacy peralta that those are the three
main
you know is that yeah for sure they're
definitely
um major figures that had a lot of
influence on me in my life
um i think i i definitely had my moments
of
dabbling in fame where it's like oh my
god you gotta give us an example
going you know like oh look you got
invited to this event you got invited to
this one like like
yeah i should that well okay that that
was a different
different level that was actually
accidental but i'm talking about like
i'm more
in the sort of mid-2000 range okay
when things were you know our video game
was was hitting and
and there were just all these
opportunities and i thought like oh this
is the life i'm supposed to lead i'm
supposed to be
a you know this sort of celebrity and
and then i started going and i realized
it was pretty empty and i think that was
probably my saving grace was that i did
get a taste of that and i was like i
don't what am i doing here
i don't and i but i always had that
sense of not belonging
because um what's wrong with this
um here i'll just pull this off there
you go yeah so i i always had the sense
of not belonging and
and that came from being a skater and
that came from being a skater in the era
of
skating not being cool oh dude i was i
was right in it man
so but but it's still like even so you
know
fast forward all that stuff um
to literally two days ago i was at the
oscars still
just feeling so out of place like what
am i doing
i didn't watch it but um but my girl
she she came home from her like girls
party to watch
yeah which they do every year and uh she
was like dude tony hawk was there
and uh i was like at first i was like
jealous because i've never
but um i uh i remember you posting about
the
the um the documentary about the story
it made sense to me and they won that
they won yeah whether they went they won
the documentary category
they won the short documentary category
yeah that's great so it's called um
it's called learning to skateboard in a
war zone if you're a girl
and it's about the scada stan project in
afghanistan
and how that came to be was the
this obviously they worked on the
documentary for a few years
and then they contacted me because i'm a
board member and they said hey we want
to have a screening in la
we're trying to raise awareness maybe
submit it for oscar
and this is only about six months ago so
i went tried to you know do my best to
get people there raise awareness and
do a little speech before i because i
had visited the skate of stem projects
and
and then next thing you know they're
they're nominated
and then they said and and i remember
this is how this all
happened ali from skate of stan who
started the project
um he's like we got a nomination and
then i just wrote back to him like cool
see at the oscars as a joke
right right and and then he's like yeah
i'm trying to get a ticket
and then about a week later he's like i
got my ticket i'll see you there i'm
like oliver i don't have a ticket
have you ever been to one before no
you get an oscar no no no so so what
happened was
then i said oliver i don't have a ticket
i was just kidding he's like oh i'll try
to get you a ticket
so then he goes back and about a week
later and this is just
this is like a week before it's even
happening and he says i got you a ticket
i was like that's crazy serious right
now
but then i said well what about can my
wife go
and he's like i could barely get you a
ticket like i don't that's not possible
then two days before the oscars i got a
call from the academy and they said hey
would you
like you and your wife like to sit in
the orchestra section
then i don't know anything about the
oscars i'd assume that's a dope section
to be in
yeah yeah i'm like like
keanu's right here josh gad all the cast
from 1917.
over here is parasite next to okay uh
laura dern um who else
uh keanu is just rad huh he's pretty rad
yeah
so but then so afterwards then i get the
truth and what happened was
two of the main producers of parasite
got stuck in china
because of the coronavirus
[Laughter]
that's great i mean dude i mean i love
how
how much humility tony has because it's
like
if you look at it from the perspective
of like the oscars and here you've got
this
this documentary about skateboarding
like
what an opportunity to have tony hawk
sit there and be affiliated with that
film but i would feel weird if i had
really no relation to it that would be
awkward for me
right because then it would just be like
oh you know it would be more for show
and more to try to like draw attention
to myself but i did have a hand in
getting it there so i felt good about
that sure um
are you kidding me a documentary about
skateboarding yeah that's crazy yeah is
it in the oscars
i still haven't seen it man i'm guessing
i love tony hawk and he's raising money
to build skate parks by selling
a limited number of these hand signed
legendary photos and there's a link in
the bio to get one
so help tony hawk build skateparks
okay buy a hand signed
freaking print yeah dude
yeah dude